isolated dragon that is E4 C5 Knight to
F3 Knight to C6 D4 C caps D4 Knight
captures D4 and now the move G6
is very popular at all level of chairs
and on top of everything there is a
trappy line which has been recommended
in many books and videos
and that goes as follow
Knight to C3 Bishop to G7
Bishop to E3
and after Knight to F6 the main line
continues with Bishop to C4 where black
has two choices
the normal here is to Castle but Queen
to A5 where blackheads sets up his
tricky platform
and it is very obvious the attraction of
this line is huge as
white has the only one move here which
is right namely Castle as if you place
any other moves then at least black get
upon advantage
I have covered all this tricky line from
the black perspective in my door
teachers tricks24 so if you are
interested then you can definitely watch
it out
for example there is a famous game where
super Grand Master Nakamura excess of
2700 plus once continue with Knight to
B3 and after Queen to B4 he casually
played Bishop to D3 only to face the
root shock
back
so black is a clear Pawn up and the
Tactical point is
after Bishop takes E4 black wants to
give up the bishop pair
but in return after Pawn Tech C3
Queen takes E4 and when both the side
castles if you count the material not
only black come out as a complete Pawn
Advantage but look at the white Pawn
structure on the queen side they are
completely shattered and no wonder even
the strength of Nakamura cannot stop the
defeat
so it is pretty clear that white has to
castle at this point
and in fact it is now white who has sets
up a cunning trap
well black should continue here with
moves such as d6o Castle however many
black player thinks that why not
continue with Queen to B4 which is in
fact as per the database played in more
than 2200 games and it looks logical as
well you are attacking two spores and
when white Defenders
what else but Knight captures E4 winning
a very important Pawn
so everything looks so cool except one
problem that black is now losing by
force
how let's check out
number one what actually black player is
hoping for that white can take this
Knight
so that after Knight xd4 he is upon all
and the further tactical justification
is after C3 black can throw this in
between check
and when white captured it he can safely
capture on e4 and indeed remain on the
driver's seat
so that is the reason why Knight
captures E4 is completely out of the
equation here
and the correct start for our counter
trap is Knight captures C6
removing the piece that has been
attacked by the black pieces
okay black queen get attacked and black
can go wrong one more time if we
continue with Knight capture C3 as after
this y can simply capture the queen and
after Knight captures D1 and root
captures D1 it is wide Who emerge with a
piece advantage
so this variation is right out of the
equation that means black has to take
this Knight
and it doesn't matter however they
recapture
the most famous choice is btec C6
afterwards
now you see the point as this queen is
the only piece who is defending this
Knight so what we are going to do is
eject this queen with moose such as A3
and
suddenly black and no longer hold on to
his night
pay attention guys as game is not over
because black has a nice tactical
resource here namely Knight capture C3
counter-attacking the White Queen so
that if white foolishly take this Knight
then after Queen capture C3 this time
black is two Pawn Advantage
so obviously we can't take this Knight
that means we have to move the queen
and thankfully after White's next reply
more or less black can resigned the game
and I hope you indeed see Queen to F3 a
multi-purpose move number one attacking
on F7 number two very important
getting the black queen
okay black and still plays some tricky
moves Knight to E2 check
hoping that white can take the night so
the black queen can escape
but no way white is going to play King
to H1 and now indeed F7 is dropping and
in fact the game
one of the recent game where the black
player is in excess of 2600 continue
with Queen to D6 and white shows the
power of his position by first giving
this check and after King to d8 he
regained the piece back and attacked the
black Rogue
okay black has two choices
and amongst them if Queen to F6 then
white can simply exchange the queen and
then place the move Bishop to C4 which
wins the piece on the spot
so that is right out of the equation
and in the game black tried Rook to E8
which I don't think so solves any
problem as white has a nasty reply here
did you spot it
congratulations if you see the move
Bishop to F7 which by force wins the
game
well Queen to F6 has been tried but I
think this is a big time blunder as
after the simple sequence
Queen takes F6 phone takes F6
Bishop takes E8 King takes E8 and now
sting in the tail Rook to even and that
Knight is a complete goner
you might say hang on black and play
Bishop to A6 right
well yep he can accept the problem is
after Rook to D1 white has a simple
threat namely Rook to D2 and then
nabbing the two P's for a rook and
emerge with a clear Bishop advantage
and this is exactly happen in the game
black plays D5 white indeed execute his
plan and after King to F7 what else Rook
takes E2 Bishop takes E2 and Rook
captures E2
where the dust is settled down and
indeed what is emerged with a clear
peace advantage
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this amazing counter trap in the
excited dragon
remember after the castle
if your opponent goes with his tricky
business Queen to B4 then after Bishop
to B3 and Knight captures E4
white played just one move Knight
captures C6 and after this no matter
however black wriggles it is wide who
will come out as a victorious in this
line
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will see you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care